vous parlez du pouvoir vous dire je n'ai
pas aimé le pouvoir car sa prétention me
fait rire
pourtant vous avez exercé le pouvoir
j'aime pas pour recevoir des ordres
ouais mais je n'aime pas beaucoup non
plus en donner donc il vaut mieux que je
m'abstienne de ce genre d'activité et
j'ai été j'ai été j'ai dirigé un journal
mais un journal je la veux particulier
parce qu'on ne donne pas vraiment dans
jaune est celui qui va donner des ordres
mais je n'aime pas beaucoup les formes
de pouvoir c'est vrai j'aime pas le
subit et je n'aime pas beaucoup
l'exercer je sais pas l'éloge vous savez
il faut bien qu'ils aient des gens qui
exercent d'ailleurs je n'ai aucun jeu
n'est pas du tout de dédain pour les
gens qui exercent le pouvoir simplement
moi j'en suis pas je ne suis pas friand
voilà